After being cancelled after only three seasons,
fan outcry led to “Longmire” being rescued by
Netflix for another three seasons. But now that
it’s over, are you longing for more "Longmire?"
These 15 shows will fill the neo-Western hole
in your heart left behind by the beloved series.
Amazon Prime's "Bosch" is the perfect example
of a show that captures the vibe of "Longmire"
without sharing its Western setting.
The series stars Titus Welliver,
who sci-fi fans may know as the Man in Black from
"Lost," as Los Angeles detective Harry Bosch. Not
unlike "Longmire," the series is based on a
set of novels written by Michael Connelly.
This procedural drama is structured by "case
of the week" crimes that Bosch needs to solve.
Simultaneously, it features overarching,
season-long — and even series-long —
story arcs that weave in greater themes.
As the seasons progress, Connelly's other
"Bosch" books, of which there are over 20,
are mined for story inspiration. The series
wrapped up its seventh and final season in 2021,
but fans didn't have to weep for long: The show
quickly earned a spinoff. Fans of "Longmire" are
sure to like how "Bosch" intertwines characters,
individual episodes, and big-picture plots.
If you've got a hankering for a real Western after
enjoying "Longmire," go back in time with "Hell
on Wheels." This historical drama ran on AMC for
five seasons from 2011 to 2016. The series is set
in the years after the American Civil War, and
stars Anson Mount as Cullen Bohannon, a former
Confederate soldier who joins the Union Pacific
Railroad. Colm Meaney co-stars as Thomas "Doc"
Durant, a real historical figure who invested in
the first transcontinental railroad. Common plays
Elam Ferguson, a recently freed enslaved person
who becomes Cullen's assistant and bodyguard.
The series, and the characters, move across
the country as the railroad is built.
This allows for many procedural scenarios. The
laborers, surveyors, builders, sex workers,
and everyone else who travels along with
the encampment refer to themselves as
"Hell on wheels," giving the show its
title. They're well worth getting to know.
In AMC's "The Son," British actor Pierce Brosnan
heads to the American West. From that simple
starting point, things get complicated, as "The
Son" likes to play with time. The main setting
is 1917, where Brosnan plays Eli McCullough,
the iconic "First Son of Texas." He secures
his legacy as a wealthy oil tycoon by killing,
threatening, and deceiving his way to the top.
“In this life, if you don’t
move forward, you die.”
"The Son" also takes the viewer back to 1850,
where a young Eli, played by Jacob Lofland,
learns the ways of the Comanche and becomes a
respected warrior. The show also jumps forward
to 1988, where Eli's granddaughter Jeannie,
played by Lois Smith, uncovers family secrets.
It's a pretty neat setup, and though AMC only gave
the show two seasons, it's still worth a watch.
The FX action-drama "Sons of Anarchy" could
certainly fill the "Longmire" hole in your
heart. The series follows the members of
an outlaw motorcycle club rooted in the
Central Valley of California. Charlie
Hunnam stars as Jackson "Jax" Teller,
the vice president of the Sons of Anarchy
Motorcycle Club. He begins to question his
role in the club after discovering the journals of
his deceased father, the club's former president.
Throughout the series, the club is involved in
many illegal activities. So, while this series
may be like "Longmire" in many respects, the long
arm of the law is considered the bad guy here,
always looking to shut them down and toss their
members in jail. The series also addresses racism
in the world of outlaw motorcycle clubs, the
role of vigilantism, and government corruption.
The Netflix series "Bloodline" begins with
John Rayburn's ominous voice. He says,
"Sometimes you know something's coming. You can
feel it. In the air. In your gut. And you don't
sleep at night. The voice in your head is telling
you that something is going to go terribly wrong
and there's nothing you can do to stop it.
That's how I felt when my brother came home."
As you might guess from this intense introduction,
"Bloodline" is steeped in secrets,
crime, and tense reunions.
The story follows the Rayburn siblings of the
Florida Keys when the aforementioned black sheep
of the family returns from who-knows-where. His
presence causes enough tension to kill off the
family patriarch. While "Longmire" might be set
out west, "Bloodline" offers up the same thrilling
ambiance in a more paradisiacal atmosphere.
Come on in, the turquoise water is fine.
HBO's "Deadwood" ran for three seasons in
the '00s, wrapping up years later with a
2019 movie. The show is a historical Western
set in Deadwood, South Dakota in the 1870s.
Timothy Olyphant stars as Seth Bullock,
a sheriff-turned-hardware store owner.
Ian McShane plays saloon owner Al Swearengen.
As Deadwood grows from a ramshackle spot into a
blossoming town, South Dakota itself prepares for
a more official, law-abiding existence. That means
cleaning up the rabble. Complex drama ensues,
weaving together episodic arcs and lengthier
storylines involving government corruption,
loyalty, and the early days of American crime.
"Deadwood" is well known for its sharp
writing and stellar performances. It has
also become known for its incredible amount of
swearing. One report counts a total of 2,980
f-bombs dropped during the show's three
seasons, with one occurring every 1.56 seconds.
"Deadwood" offers up the Western
procedural ambiance "Longmire" fans
crave and a degree of profanity so
immense, it's almost awe-inspiring.
Kevin Costner’s most recent western adventure
is a modern one called "Yellowstone,"
which makes its home on the Paramount Network. The
series follows the Dutton family, sixth-generation
owners of the largest working ranch in the
country. Costner stars as the patriarch,
John Dutton. The drama hinges on outsiders'
attempts at gaining access to the Duttons'
land, conflicts with the neighboring Native
reservation, and a whole lot of family secrets.
The Dutton family features three grown kids:
Kayce, Jamie, and Beth. Their lives form much
of the backbone of the series, encompassing
substance abuse, illicit relationships,
and frustrated dreams. All in all, "Yellowstone"
is an emotional, exciting, and altogether
engrossing drama with Western flair. In short,
perfect for anyone who loves "Longmire."
After starring in "Deadwood," Timothy Olyphant
travelled into the future some 130 years to
star in FX's modern drama "Justified." He plays
Deputy U.S. Marshal Raylan Givens. After shooting
a Miami mobster, Givens is transferred
to Kentucky, where he happens to be from.
It's not a happy homecoming. Drama, violence,
secrets, and lies ensue — often tangled together.
"Justified" ran for six seasons and was
critically acclaimed throughout its run.
Walton Goggins' performance as Boyd Crowder,
a white supremacist preacher who heads up
the area's criminal underground, earned
particular praise, among other stellar roles.
“Justified" is based on author Elmore
Leonard's work, especially "Fire in
the Hole." The success of "Justified" inspired
Leonard to write another Givens-centric novel,
"Raylan." The book came out in 2012,
shortly before Leonard's death in 2013.
Here's where we get a little international with
this list. "Tin Star" is a British crime drama
that revolves around a London detective who's
tasked with becoming the police chief of a
Canadian town in the Rocky Mountains. It's
"Old West" meets "Old World" — not exactly
a common combination, but, as it turns out,
a fascinating one. Tim Roth stars as James
"Jim" Worth, the detective who moves his
family to Canada to escape his troubled past.
The weird thing about this show is that when
Jim drinks, he becomes his violent alter-ego,
Jack Devlin. It's intense, surprisingly
fun, and a bit weird, all at the same time.
Christina Hendricks co-stars as Elizabeth
Bradshaw, an executive with North Stream Oil,
the company that dominates the town. She
tries to balance Chief Worth's presence with
the biker gangs, criminals, and oil workers
of the town. "Tin Star" spans three seasons,
which first aired on Sky Atlantic, then
moved to Amazon. Interestingly, however,
Season 3 — or Series 3, as the Brits call it —
takes place back in Liverpool, England. This omits
the Western feel of the show, but not to worry:
It still maintains its crime-thriller ambiance.
While some of the shows on this list can get
pretty dark and dramatic, "Hap and Leonard"
is one that embraces its humor. This mystery
crime drama stars James Purefoy as Hap Collins,
a blue-collar dude who's spent time in prison, as
well as Michael Kenneth Williams as Leonard Pine,
a Black, gay Vietnam veteran. Set in the
1980s, the series takes place in east Texas,
where Hap and Leonard team up
on a get-rich-quick scheme.
Soon enough, they pull ex-wives, townsfolk,
other criminals, and lawmen into their fold.
The show was created by novelist Joe R. Lansdale
and is based on his "Hap and Leonard" novels.
In many ways, it's unlike any other show on
this list, blending together comedy, grit,
lawlessness, and outright absurdity.
If you're longing for that "Longmire"
attitude but you'd also like to crack a smile once
in a while, "Hap and Leonard" is a great choice.
“I do what I can.”
We're going across the pond again for this next
entry. Though ITV's "Broadchurch" doesn't have
the Western edge that "Longmire" does, its
fascinating portrait of a town in crisis will
no doubt lure you in. The series is set in the
fictional English village of Broadchurch. Here,
detectives Alec Hardy, played by David Tennant,
and Ellie Miller, played by Olivia Coleman,
are forced to team up, despite the vast
difference in their personalities. Season
1 follows their journey as they attempt to
solve the enigmatic killing of a local boy.
Broadchurch being a small town, other townsfolk
soon become involved. Things grow more and more
complex in Seasons 2 and 3, wrapping the
whole series up in a twisty, mysterious bow.
The setting of the show provides just as much
ambiance as the chilling crimes themselves. The
white cliffs, gray skies, and rough seas
are basically characters unto themselves.
If the mystery aspect of "Longmire" drew you in,
you'll find "Broadchurch" downright addictive.
We're staying in England for this next entry
— but can you blame us? The leading man is
just that good. In the BBC One crime drama
"Luther," Idris Elba stars as John Luther,
a police detective for the Serious Crime Unit,
which sounds silly, but is official. Luther often
gets sucked into the crimes he investigates,
especially those of serial killer Alice Morgan,
played by Ruth Wilson. The two spend the majority
of the series as both nemeses and companions,
infusing this dark crime
thriller with electric tension.
Luther is technically a miniseries, with only
two to six episodes per season, making the entire
five-season series totally bingeable. There was
supposed to be an American remake, but it fell
apart back in 2017. There is still chatter about
a "Luther" movie, so you best get into it now!
Are you up for a little sci-fi-horror to go
along with your neo-Western? If so, SyFy's
"Wynonna Earp" might be right up your alley. It
stars Melanie Scrofano as the titular character,
the great-great-granddaughter of legendary Old
West lawman Wyatt Earp. That legacy isn't all
it's cracked up to be. She's haunted by the
outlaws her ancestor killed, who take the
form of undead revenants. Luckily, on her 27th
birthday, she discovers that she's inherited the
ability to send them back to Hell, with a little
help from "Peacemaker," her ancestor's magic gun.
"Wynonna Earp" ran for four seasons
on SyFy before being canceled in 2021.
Don't count it out just yet, though — the show's
passionate fanbase is working overtime
to secure the future of "Wynonna Earp."
If you're short on time and looking for
a single-season miniseries to binge,
check out Netflix's "Godless." Set in 1884,
"Godless" begins when young outlaw Roy Goode,
played by Jack O'Connell, runs out
on his cruel mentor. He soon stumbles
onto La Belle, New Mexico, a town run
and populated almost entirely by women.
As it turns out, most of the men of
La Belle died in a mining accident,
leaving the town's women to run it as they
please. Jeff Daniels also stars as Frank Griffin,
the venomous outlaw Goode flees from. The
miniseries was a hit, earning its cast
and crew a handful of Emmy Awards and a
place on multiple best-of-the-year lists.
Banshee captures neo-Western style
much like "Longmire" does, with a
major geographical twist. Set in Pennsylvania
Amish Country, "Banshee" stars Antony Starr
as an ex-con who assumes the identity of the
town's incoming sheriff, to hide from a powerful
crime lord called Mr. Rabbit. When the sheriff
is killed, the ex-con, whose name we never learn,
swipes his identity and shows up in Banshee,
PA masquerading as the town's new lawman.
"Banshee" earned mixed
reviews. Some watchers love it,
while others criticize its intense
violence and gratuitous sex scenes.
So yeah, it's a bit more wild than "Longmire,"
but it still utilizes that same gritty,
procedural style in a unique setting. The show
ran for four seasons on Cinemax and definitely
lives up to the lurid nature of that network's
reputation. It’s at least worth checking out.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.